un couple d'agriculteurs qui vont à la
vie est hélas d'hab
la dame a le niveau bas je vais je fais
lâcheté des culottes et l'agriculteur un
peu comme didier de l'amour est dans le
pré tu vois il fait n'a pas y aller elle
dit mais pourquoi tu viens le cul d'une
moissonneuse-batteuse tuer le cul d'une
moissonneuse-batteuse lugano alors là si
elle fait une première boutique
historiens deux trois quatre boutiques
rien du tout ne trouve pas de culotte
il rentre le soir venu ils se couchent
et el marikh et dans le lit qui à côté
il fait j'aimerais j'aimerais bien un
câlin la fia si tu veux pas faire le
gala parce que c'est pas met en route la
moissonneuse batteuse pour atout p'tit
brin d'herbe
m
par contre j'ai noté tout celle de
ludivine on va se régaler alors l'examen
final dans un hôpital psychiatrique
examen final
maintenant il reste trois foot a compris
et le docteur et 10 boss qu'on va faire
pour tester leur tendresse
on va leur donner un appel chacun
d'accord il ordonne à la fin chacun le
premier veau le voir le premier sur le
rap en train de faire céder roues avant
et unies monsieur quoi n'est pas guéri
celui-là est passé au deuxième
le deuxième mis encore sur le lab en
train de faire des royals
je n'en menais pas guéri il arrive au
troisième le troisième il a le la pala
et le caresse a dit lula à lui les
guérés font ils valoir aider mais il est
vite et bien avec ton apaisant très bien
que tu fais pas à moto comme témoin par
le média et son parti mm
[Applaudissements]
lola alors c'est c'est un médecin
cancérologue qui est avec son patient et
lui dit bon ben j'ai une mauvaise
nouvelle est une bonne nouvelle enfin
une bonne ou une mauvaise dans l'ordre
que vous voulez bon allez je vais
commencer par la mauvaise vous êtes
malheureusement en phase terminale le
cancer se généralise et voilà il vous
reste plus que quelques semaines à vivre
mec est déprimé et puis dit bon je vous
appelle vous demandez quelle est la
bonne edit vous voyez là la blonde la
balle à la grande avec l'étalon le
décolleté sourire ravageur
c'est ce soir que janick
[Applaudissements]